hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar disease
model generation
five steps to a 3d cancer spheroid model
i'm donna trollinger senior global
market development manager at thermo
fisher scientific
and i will be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
hosted by libraries
brought to you by thermo fisher
scientific
to learn more visit our website at
thermofisher.com
3d models we encourage you to
participate today by submitting any
questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical
issues here as well if you have any
trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continue education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome my thumb
official colleague and today's speaker
application scientist edwin gauss edwin
you may now begin your presentation
everyone my name is edwin golis and i'm
the field application scientist for 3d
and advanced cell models here at thermo
fisher
thank you for taking the time to listen
to the webinar today and today's webinar
will highlight the five steps to
generating cancer steroid models
here's an agenda highlighting with a
webinar i'll cover today first we'll
start
with some background discussing what 3d
cell models are
then i'll review some considerations
when developing cancer spirit models
the main part of this talk will examine
the five steps that will require to
generate cancer spiroid
finally we'll end the presentation with
a summary and a list of available online
resources
before i go into the presentation i want
to take the time to acknowledge our
global r d
teams who put an extensive effort to
provide material
for this webinar
so why do we create 3d models
we want to we want to create an in vitro
approach
to predict human biology
to recapture human biology we want to be
able to mimic the inputs that
impact the body and create a
representative cell system
that can capture these phenomena as with
the human biology we want aim to measure
changes to these inputs in our creative
cellular system
to give us a glimpse of what we would
expect to see in an in vivo or human
setting
we want to build these cell models to
predict outputs that best translate to
humans
so what do we consider a 3d model
until it all gives a nice definition uh
of what we consider a 3d model is it's a
cellular cluster
from a particular cell source that is
capable of proliferating and self
organizing and showing some sort of
similarities to the tissue
that it came from the diagram on the
right here
illustrates the different in vitro
models going from increasing complexity
as you go from left to right
starting with the 2d monolayer culture
these are your typical immortalized
cells that are grown in a plastic
dish or flask it's usually your drug's
first
exposure to a living system this
technique has been around for several
decades and is used for doing
early stage toxicity effects efficacy
and looking at mechanism of action
as you move to the middle of this
diagram we increase the complexity by
utilizing
multiple cell types in what we call the
co-culture system
in the co-culture system we want to see
how the interaction of these multiple
cell types
can more represent the in vivo setting
closer than what you'd see in the 2d
setting
organized chip modalities incorporate
microfluidic systems that bring
perfusion and flow capabilities
to your 3d model and complexity can also
be increased when utilized cells that
are procured directly from tissues
as opposed to more life cells which are
usually used for traditional 2d models
and these tissue derived cells can be
used in either co
culture or a monolayer system but what
we support here at thermal fissure and
will be the basis of this webinar
are 3d models they can be the
self-aggregated models such as
spheroids or organoids or models that
are constructed
with the use of a buyer printer which
you have control over the shape
uh the deposition of your cells and
biomaterials depending on the program
and how you program the bioprinter for
your use
steroids and organic terminology can get
a little confusing so i like to
delineate between the two uh because uh
these terms are used interchangeably
quite a bit steroids
or cellular clusters derived from an
immortalized or primary cell source
which can grow and proliferate exhibit
some sort of physiological relevance
but they do not organize or
differentiate into a new cell type
so what you start with at the beginning
of your protocol will be the same so as
you end up at the end
but organoids on the other hand are
derived from a stem cell source
they can grow and proliferate show that
relevance but they will differentiate
or organize into a new cell type or
multiple cell types
at the end of the protocol so what you
start with at the
beginning of your organo protocol will
be different what you see at the end
given that virtually every feature of a
cell's environment is different
when you go from two-dimensional to
three dimensions it's important to study
that these cells
that these cells within the
three-dimensional is important to cite
yourselves within the
context of a three-dimensional system
this is nicely summarized in this review
from genentech
but what highlights that while cells
grown in 2d create an accessible
cellular environment this environment
doesn't really represent what's actually
occurring in the in vivo setting
your cells do not grow in a single plane
they don't grow in plastic
with the media the nutrients and gas
exchange occurring in one direction
also the cells uh your cells in your
body you don't have direct access
to a drug that it's uh it's being
treated with
as shown in the image in this a549
spirit image
cells are grown in different planes with
cells
surrounding it in the x y and z plane uh
extracellular makes us interweaved in
between them showing providing more
connection
and you'll see gradients formed for the
nutrients gas exchange as well as drug
accessibility
the diagram on the right here shows the
gradients that are present say in a
tumor spheroid
there are gradients present for gas
exchange eugene
distribution as well as self
proliferation depending on where the
cells are in the model
the cells on the outer portion of the of
the model
are more proliferative as they have more
better access
to the media the growth factors
nutrients that provided
in the system while the cells that are
in the middle further away from those
components
are uh less viable and more necrotic
and this is a this is a typical
phenomena you would see
in a system that does not have vast
culture where you can
infuse or flush in or pump in the
nutrients or immediate
media or gas exchange so with these 3d
models
a combination of instrumentation and
reagents are necessary to analyze them
and this analysis is readily achieved by
use of fluorescent imaging
by combining the image systems with uh
different fluorescent reagents you're
able to visualize the relative aspects
of tumor biology
for example that we're shown here we can
examine the hypoxic nature of
a tumor spirit as well as looking at
apoptotic events in an attack 3d setting
so take a message i want to hammer with
this light is that 3d cell models that
are represent the tumor environment
and acids and instrumentation are needed
to explore this dynamic system
so when growing cancer steroids there
are certain aspects that need to be
considered
first of all spheroid size steroids can
differ in
compactness depending on the cell line
being used this image here shows four
different cancer cell lines
seen at 5000 cells per well as you can
see each of these
cells are of various sizes to
sit to obtain spheroids for use of a
specific diameter
to the downstream assay the cell seeding
density needs to be optimized
another factor to look into is how long
you have living culture
cells that are grown in 2d grow
faster than cells that are grown in 3d
some spheroids will be ready to use
within 24 hours
and that's cell line dependent while
some will require force maybe up to nine
days
the ideal spheroid is a is translucent
has a fine boundary and a minimal dark
core
as evident in this particular graph of
the day of day five for the t47d
uh steroid
some cell lines form steroids on their
own while others will
form loose or tight aggregates which
require some assistance
from a material such as an extracellular
matrix to help with the spheroid
formation
the ecms the extracellular matrix
assists with the cell the cell contacts
needed for the cells to aggregate into a
compact steroid in the image here the
pc3
cell line uh require a little bit of gel
tricks to facilitate that sphere of
formation
in the absence of this matrix you see
that the cells
gather together they don't uh form a
compact spheroid
but in the presence of gel tricks at a
differing amounts depending on the cell
density
you see the improvement in the steroid
formation
finally uh we discussed the plastic
surface required
uh primary requirements for sphere
formation is a non-inherent
surface our nephilim sphere plates uh
uh provide that low attachment surface
and they help propel the cells from
settling to the bottom and they
facilitate a uniform formation
after you spin the plate down and this
uniform secure information is key
to keeping it consistency among your
sphere replicates which can impact your
downstream assay results
so put these considerations in mind
there are methods available to create
disease models for cancer
our focus on this webinar will be on
developing breast cancer
spheroid bottles for women breast cancer
is the most
common form of cancer it is estimated
that about one out of eight women in the
us will develop an invasive cancer
during their lifetime
the push for different cancer therapies
and having having a relevant cell model
to assess threat response is key
these 3d cell mods that we're developing
for cancer become the
choice uh the model choice for basic
free kind of research
because they better represent the tumor
micro environment compared to
traditional 2d model
this webinar that will focus on the five
steps needed to develop a cancerous
feroid model and we're going to use
breast cancer as an example
these these guidelines can be
extrapolated to other cancer types as
well
so here's a snapshot of the five steps
which will go into
uh forecast generation which will be
we'll go into more detail in subsequent
slides
first we will discuss how to culture the
cells figure out which cell lines
are appropriate to reflect the cancer
you are trying to study
next we'll discuss generation of the of
the model you know optimizing the growth
conditions the seating density
for the model of choice uh then we'll
optimize this protocol
uh like as i mentioned earlier sometimes
these spheroids would have helped to
uh get them to form contact for it so
we'll uh
highlight a few optimization uh methods
to do that
next we need to characterize the model
where you take the time to
find a protocol that works we want to
make sure that this protocol provides
a spheroid model that is healthy compact
and is
the appropriate size for your for your
assessment
and then finally uh with your optimized
model you want to go to measure
do drug responses on the model to better
understand physiological effects of
drugs on your cancer system
so cells are the foundation of any cell
model and choosing the best cell line
and utilizing optimal
culture where plastics are crucial for
that cell line growth and maintenance
breast cancer there are four main types
uh for many phenotypes
of cancer which are listed here adductor
carcinoma
invasive ductal inflammatory as well as
metastatic carcinoma
the image on the right here showed two
cancer cell lines that we've optimized
here at thermo fissure we've optimized
the protocols
for developing these particular cancer
steroid models
the t47d cancer cell line is an estrogen
receptor positive line
which belongs to the invasive ductal
type where the mdamb231 which i refer to
for the rest of the presentation as 231
cells
is a triple negative breast cancer line
belonging to an adenocarcinoma type
growing and maintaining these soils
require particular media and components
but also the best culture plastics to
promote the cell a throat smoke cell
growth and healthy viable cells for
spheroid formation
we recommend though as you're culturing
yourselves that when you
are growing the cells to grow them to
about 70 to 80 percent confluency before
pathogen
packaging or harvesting and also when
you're
doing the passing or harvesting and
you're detaching them with a
dissociation reagent
be mindful of how long you incubate them
with that reagent as that can affect the
cell viability and health
of your cells and culture
next we will need to optimize the growth
condition and cell seating density to
generate our spheroid
the diagram here illustrates the steps
needed to harvest and plate your
spirit model the first thing you want to
do is achieve a single cell suspension
from the cells that we've cultured from
the previous step by lifting off the
monolayer of cells by utilizing the
dissociation reagents such as triple e
uh harvest the cells and we're going to
do a cell count utilizing
our cell counter or hemocytometer and we
want to determine the cell density
needed and then seed them into
a low attachment plate which is for a
nunchuan sphero plate
utilizing a multi-channel pipette
to kind of get them going to form
uniform steroids
after you see the cells we recommend uh
spinning them for
quickly in the center for you just to
gather
the cells allow them to clump at the
bottom of the well and then
after the spin we'll incubate them uh in
a 37 degree 5
co2 incubator uh for a certain period of
time depending on the cell type
uh which may or may not require uh
feeding of one-to-one uh feeding of
spent medium terra
to new medium based on the cell line
that you choose
with some cell lines such as a uh hela
cell line or lung cancer cell line like
a549
spheroids will form rather quickly
within 24 hours while others like the
pc3 prostate cancer of the cell line
will take five to nine days to form
steroids and that's when you probably
want to incorporate
a feeding every three or four days
a couple tips when generating these
lines that when optimizing you want to
start with cells that are highly viable
and greater than 90 percent as lower
viable ones may not form steroids as
well
the multichannel pipette has been
mentioned in the
steps here probably be your best friend
in terms of getting these onto the plate
so
make sure you have uh you have one handy
uh for administering the cells to the uh
to the
attachment plates and when adding them
to the plates or utilizing the the
pipette
make sure that you don't touch the
bottom of the uh of the look
of the of the plates and you may scratch
the bottom which can affect
uh the cells from sticking to the uh
which which may affect the cells from
foreign
if the plates are scratched and then to
help with the sphere information
mentioned uh spin the plate uh shortly
after seeding to facilitate the cells
clumping together
and get the spirits to form quicker
so depending on the cell type chosen
steroid formation may differ
depending on the cell that used so
for the two breast cancer cell lines
that we've used the t47d
and and the 231s it takes them both
about three to four days to form
uh steroids but as you can see the line
the cell lines
behave differently they look visually
different after those uh after that time
frame
so in the above example for the t-47d on
the left
uh through experimentation from the r d
team it was noted that
going above 8 000 cells per well
this particular cell line does not uh
yield a uniform steroid
and it's evident here as you can see
with the ten thousand
um uh the ten thousand subscribers
they're
they're quite large especially at day
four you're seeing this really dark sort
of necrotic core
on the forming in the middle the 231
cells so
at that same time frame can actually go
up to 20k per well
in the same timeframe and still yield
reproduce reproducible spheroids so
again
different cell types differ
will behave differently when forming
steroids
so even with the optimal growth and
scenic parameters set from uh the
generation portion some further tweaks
may be needed
uh to generate your steroids
some spell uh some cells with foreign
well some finicky cell types will not
and this is evident here in the t47d uh
which are ready in roughly four to seven
days depending on your cell density
uh but for a finicky type such as the
231 cells
some modifications are required in this
case it required a small amount of an
extracellular matrix in this case
collagen one to help with the spheroid
formation as you can see
uh in in the graph on the right of the
231 cells without the collagen
cells do clump but you aren't uh they
are just forming cell aggregates
not compact defined spheres which would
be useful for for when we're uh
testing drug responses on chemo so uh
for this it was determined uh that a
small amount
of in this case three migrants per
million collagen for uh
for the 231 cells required to get that
uh
nice compact spirit to form
so again different cells will also
respond differently to the ecm
so with the 231 cells it mentioned that
collagen
was one of choice but to get to that
point we had we did
try different ecm to see if particular
one worked better
as you can see trying another material
methyl cellulose
or different concentrations of a base
basement membrane extracts such as gel
tracks
uh we tried those but they didn't uh
form that nice tight steroid as
collagen did and in this instance we
used a high amount of collagen
50 micrograms per ml of collagen once
you've found
the amount that you need it's
recommended that you do a titration of
that
of that ecm to see the least amount
that's required to form the steroids
and you can see we were able to tighter
it down to three micrograms per mil
which was uh the chosen uh the chosen
amount
uh for going forward with the 231 cells
to form steroids
as you can see if you go with uh you can
go with higher amounts but there's a
certain point where
too much ecm may actually be detrimental
to
forming a nice steroid
so just a couple tips when uh doing the
top of optimization
these ecms many of them are temperature
dependent and
i will polymerize above when you get
close to
37 degrees when you're diluting the ecm
stocks make sure that the
medium that you're using are pre-chilled
it's cold as
the ecm will tend to polymerize quickly
when the temperature rises
and for this particular cell line the
231 cells uh
when you see the cells it's recommended
that you
let the cells sit in the in the in the
well for 24 hours
let them clump and then add your medium
containing your ecm
and this technique for this bigger cell
line helps
facilitate that uniform severed
formation
forcing cells to grow in suspension for
severe formation puts them under a lot
of stress
so it's important to assess cell health
and viability before using steroids for
downstream acid
since every cell type has a different
shape spheroid size may not correlate
with cell seeking density
the graph and the image is shown here
these
47 d cells yield bigger steroids
compared to the 231 cells
eight in in this example 8000 cells
for both cell types were seeded in the
uh in the sphero plates
to yield steroids and the t470 yielded
a diameter of 600 of 600 microns after
four days
for the under the same seeding density
the different cell type
231 cell geology cells that were a
diameter of 300 to 350 within that same
time
and this type of imaging was able to be
done utilizing a
a bright field microscope which allowed
for capturing
these periods over days and measuring
the sphero size and roundness as shown
here
also there are several agents that are
available for assessing cell viability
uh that are can be done through image
based methods as well as microplate
based methods and here we're going to
look at a place a plate-based readout
the press-to-blue cell viability reagent
used here
measures mitochondrial activity through
reduction a reduction reaction
which will give you a fluorescent signal
this assay allows you to monitor the
cell viability and health
over time in this example uh
the in this example the press of blue
reagent was observed that the 231 cells
uh the viability increased over time
indicating
that during this time frame for both
time points that the cells were healthy
and dividing but the
measurement didn't give a give you an
indication of how many cells were dead
so while it did provide viability uh
it was it's a useful tool for getting a
quick assessment
for health as well as looking at the
size the effect of a site
of cytotoxicity on drugs in sort of a
screening aspect
these acids require the incubation of
the spheroids with uh particular with
their respective reagents
and to be imaged by utilizing a
tool such as a confocal microscope or a
flesh and reader
or as well as a plate reader such as our
barrier skin lux multi-mode
plate reader
here we look now here we look at an
image-based cell
cell health assay the live dead imaging
kit helped
here help visualize the measurement over
days as seen in the accumulation of dead
cells
the red stain at the core of the
spheroids with higher seeding densities
so compared to four day old 231 cells
the
seven day old steroids were found to
have more dead cells in the core
uh similarly for the d for dad and i
shown here the steroids with the high
cell density
had more cells uh in the core and that
and that is index and that is consistent
with our
uh with our uh finding that if you grow
the t47 d
cells higher than 8000 wells for at
eight thousand cells per well
that they will grow uh these that is not
an optimal
density as the cells will start forming
necrotic core
uh with that increased cell size and
this occurs because there's less access
of the cells in the middle to nutrients
and oxygen as indicated before
so spirit integrity or sphericity can be
measured by using the
dye eye stain the dye eye is a
lipophilic membrane stain that is weakly
fluorescent until it's incorporated into
the cell membrane
in an aggregate all cells are easily
acceptable with the dye whereas
the compactness of the spheroid prevents
the dye from entering the core
and is concentrated on the outer layers
compact steroid would limit entry of the
stain towards its core
resulting in a ring-like stain pattern
as we see
for the 231 spirit
so there are several as there are
several assays available for you to
characterize your mouth
in addition to the ones that i've
mentioned these include hypoxia and
apoptotic readings which are
highlighted earlier as well as looking
at changes in cell proliferation
as well as oxidative stress
so when characterizing the 3d model most
of these acids were optimized in 2d
and need may need to be altered for
use in the 3d model so steroids are more
resistant to diet penetration compared
to
monolayers where the dyes have direct
access to the cells so
you may need to increase your incubation
time and reagents and possibly the
concentration that you use
for plate-based readouts such as the
virus and lux plate reader
depending on the type of rita will
determine the type of read
setting you would use on your plate
reader for example if
the reading is a media based readout
you'd want to use the top read function
whereas the
reading is a cell base you'd want to use
the bottom read function
and finally cell behavior and cell
health can be measured over time if your
instrument has the capability of
utilizing an onstage incubator
to record changes in the spheroid or
phenomena of the sphere right over time
so after assessment for cell health and
viability of our spheroids
these healthy spirits can be used for
various downstream acids
so you've taken the time to you know
generate this viable breast cancer
spirit model
now it's time to see how uh this model
can respond to
uh two different types of therapies an
example here
the 231 cells were dosed with differing
amounts of the apoptotic
inducing drug etophyside as you can see
here from the
images here that cell size is decreased
and looking at the at the graph on the
right the
a apoptosis measurement was markedly
increased
starting at six micrograms at six
micromolar of the drug
and these behaviors can be measured and
analyzed using imaging systems such as
our
cell insight cx7 high content system
so here you're able to image them get
the nice in-depth picture but also
quantify the measurement that you are uh
trying to detect here
[Music]
changes in self-propagation can also be
measured when assessing
uh drug efficacy in this example
uh we're using the t-47d spheroids and
treating them
with a hundred nanomolar of quality
signs for
72 hours self proliferation here was
measured using a
clicking edu self life separation kit
and imaged and analyzed again using
our cx7 high content system the drug of
a level of drug clearly impacted the
cell proliferation is
evident here in the images and in the
graph what's great about the self
proliferation kit is that it also helps
you visualize the spatial orientation
for proliferating cells and cells in the
periphery of the sphere will have a
stronger
uh positive proliferative signal than
those in the core again because those
cells
are more closer and have more access to
the nutrients
in media that's present in the system
so when performing your uh just response
in your measurements
you want to utilize the instrumentation
such as console imaging
with laser elation laser illumination as
well as
the ability to optical optical section
the destroyed
provide in-depth state and spatial
information
about the response that you're seeing in
your spheroid
and when you perform these assays you're
going through the protocols
make sure you avoid multiple plate
washes when
when you can as these washes can
dislodge a steroid
which will make the imaging a bit more
difficult
so in summary um hopefully to capture
that
uh 3d cell models represent the
individual environment more actually
than traditional
2d cell model especially in the cancer
setting
the cancer spheroids that we can be
generated utilizing the five steps that
we've highlighted
throughout this webinar by using the
right
plastics the right media an ecm if
needed
and following these tips and tricks a
uniform and recreational spheroids can
be generated
can be generated quite easily and i hope
this webinar can highlight that our
portfolio our 3d portfolio like thermo
fisher supports that robust generation
characterization and various hyphen
applications for
analysis of 3d cancer spirit we're able
to support you
throughout the whole workflow from
creation characterization and analysis
uh here at thermal fischer for 3d model
when i highlight here some
uh online research that we have to help
you in terms of
developing your 3d model visit our
website
at thermofisher.com for more information
on how to create 3d models
uh following our friendly url for 3d
protocols
uh much like the cell lines we talked
about here the 231
and the t47d and our rnd team has
characterized
uh eight uh total cancer cell lines
terms optimizing their protocols uh
receiving densities
and of characterization and the high
some examples of high quality assays
for various cancer cell lines and their
walk through in
really nice detail on this particular
site so it's a great way to
uh to uh to start modeling different
types of cancers
based on these protocols we also have a
3d cell culture handbook
which is an encyclopedia of 3d knowledge
in one place
it really goes in in depth into the cell
culture workflow
different technologies available
materials reagents assays
and instrumentation you may need it's a
great resource
for those looking to transition from 2d
to 3d but also
those who are looking to improve on
their own 3d knowledge
with various application notes on our 3d
resources
url uh highlighting this particular
one that we discussed in the webinar but
also highlighting the other
workflows we support for 3d such as
neural organoids
hepatic steroids for looking at drug
metabolism
and also creating 3d skin tissue the
epidermal layer
skin tissue and we also have
digital e-learning modules at our
virtual learning
friendly url and we have them for a
couple of
topics uh neural organoid generation
from psds
a basics in 3d culture as well as
our latest one 3d cell model
characterization
and analysis and with that
i will take your questions thank you
thank you edwin for that really
informative presentation
uh we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located at the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started our first question
is from manuela
is it possible to deliver sirna into 3d
tumor spheroid cultures
yes actually that's a great question as
with any
delivery system uh for 3d um
for 3d models uh this can be done but
our stance here at therma is we
recommend doing
uh this type of delivery which is
usually through some sort of
transfection
with the cells in 2d first and then uh
doing your your your transfection
delivery and then creating the 3d model
we feel that it's a bit more effective
when you have the cells linearized
versus
as a cell clump there are papers out
there that uh
show that it can be done as a whole as a
self aggregate
but we recommend uh doing the uh
delivery while the cells are
uh are singularized uh before formula 3d
model but so
the short answer is yes it can be done
but we recommend doing it
with the cells in 2d first
thanks edwin and he had a follow-up
question
is it possible to perform an
immunofluorescent experiment on 3d
spheroids
for example for markers for dna damage
uh yes uh we do uh uh as part of our uh
our imaging offering you actually have
a dna damage kit which actually allows
you to study
dna damage and cytotoxicity
simultaneously
uh so as with anybody with rage
or kits you know they've been
they've been created or optimized using
2d but have been
also been optimized used in 3d culture
so
we do have a kit available uh for
looking at dna damage the
dna damage kit uh offering on our
website
great thanks evelyn uh a question from
george it's spinning down sales required
for establishing the cancer steroids
so how many steroids do i get for well
for like a 96 well plate
uh yeah a great question george um yeah
spinning down the cells as they
after seeing them uh is one of our
recommendations i think it just
facilitates the cells just being in the
middle
of the well uh given that you're using a
low attachment plate
they're going to eventually form uh this
here with or without the spinning but we
feel that
doing the spinning down post seating
just kind of gives it
uh i guess it gives it a head start and
kind of uh speeds up the process
uh to do it i think it also keeps them
in the center
and i think helps with the uniformity of
the uh of the spheroids
uh in on the protocols that we've talked
about in this webinar
we're looking at getting a single
spheroid per well in the 96 well played
based on the the methods that we've
described in this webinar
right um the next question from liz
which is the best way to evaluate
viability of a spheroid
uh yeah uh i think viability definitely
is a
key factor when developing these models
um
uh and it really depends on on your
readout uh if you're looking at an
image-based app
and i mentioned this in the uh uh a
play-based essay if you're and i
mentioned this in the webinar
i'll be looking at relative viability
where you want to have an idea of how
maybe a group of replicates or the whole
play is doing in terms of its viability
uh plate-based assays such as our presta
blue a
uh a reduction uh method that looks at
metabolic activity
can be used to give you an idea of a
quick assessment of
if the cells are healthy or if you add a
uh
a drug or a in this case a chemo
therapeutic to it
how that chemo can can affect the
overall viability so it's like a quick
assessment
that you can do on using a plate reader
if you have
looking at image-based acids which i
think are a bit more informative
like either a fluorescent microscope or
a high content imager like
our cx7 you can look at things such as
live dead staining which
highlights uh the number of live cells
which you would see
in the plate based assay but also give
you
an idea of how many dead cells are
within that individual spheroid so
as opposed to the plate-based assay
where you get relative
viability uh per plate or per number of
or
a larger number of of of spheroids
the um the image-based assay as the live
dead
cell kit will actually give you
information on the individual spirit
itself so yes you could
see that quantitative image that i think
gives you a
more in-depth way of looking at how
healthy your spirits are
okay a couple of more questions
here's one from mordecai if we are using
microfluidic 3d cultures can these
monitoring done repeatedly without
disturbing the culture
and the second part of this question is
can we
use these monitoring kits for organoids
as well
or do you have something different to
offer
uh okay uh thank you mordecai to answer
the question for the microfluidic
cultures i'm assuming
oregon on a chip uh functionality uh
in terms of monitoring and repeatedly
you could use uh
similar ways of uh similar methods that
we use for
monitoring spheroids uh in a plate uh
for sure i think it's just uh
i'll admit i uh i'm not an expert in the
microfluidic cultures but
uh these um the athletes and grains that
we that we have
are compatible with uh with the the
organized chip uh
methodology um can these kits be used
for organoids well
yes they can uh it i think with the
organizers a bit more complexity
uh within them so you'll have multiple
cell types maybe a bit more
extracellular matrix
maybe bigger so you may have to
adjust some of the parameters for the
kits that was used for a spheroid system
which is a bit more simpler usually a
single cell type
you have to adapt that to the organoids
maybe looking at increasing your
incubation time
uh a higher concentration um
so just the little things like that
you'll have to adapt to an organized
system because
uh there's a bit more cellular
complexity to your model
thanks evelyn another follow-up question
i have found that the immunofluorescence
presents after 24 hours necrotic cells
and also healthy cells and why would
um that be the reason
okay uh so in a freedom
just so i'm repeating the question here
you're seeing after uh 24 hours and
culture is
the presence of uh necrotic and healthy
cells okay so
uh it really depends on the number of
cells that are being played
for if we just use the spheroid example
uh
that you know i think higher number of
cells the
spheres will grow will definitely grow
faster to grow
larger in most cases but you'll see
uh especially with the higher cell
densities the cells in the middle will
have less access to
uh the nutrients the media uh the gas uh
the gas exchange will be a bit more
impacted on the cells in the middle
so having less access to uh to nutrients
to uh
to any growth factors or or the way to
exchange gas
will result in uh more dead cells in the
middle of a
of a um of a cell model still aggregate
that doesn't have perfusion
or vascularization which these spheroid
models have so
seeing that after 24 hours most likely
with a higher cell density
is something that can occur an option to
have less necrotic cells possibly
depending on
the cell line feeding less amount of
cells
so that uh you'd see just less of the
um it would have less impact in terms of
the
the access to nutrients compared to the
larger cell types and
some of the cell lines are that we've
optimized
uh internally that density differs
depending on which one that you're using
another question edwin is how long does
the spheroid stay viable
uh i i think we're seeing a common theme
in terms of
my answers to this it's going to start
with it depends
uh also depends on the cell line that
you're using
but also if you're going to um the the
the seating number the seating density
uh what we'll take in fact if you have
too many cells and they grow too big
you're going to see that necrotic core
that we see uh in that we saw
uh that you mentioned in the in the
previous question
so if you're going to take if you want
to grow them out longer i mean there's
and
again it's uh it depends on the selling
that uh if you're gonna if you want them
to grow longer you could
see them at a lower density you know
spin them down uh let them grow and form
the spirit
and uh do uh uh feedings uh periodically
way so they're two every three days
uh and that's that has to be optimized
as well so
i would go with the lower uh to have
them longer in culture
grow them at a lower cell density and
possibly incorporate
a a media feed at some point during the
protocol
i mean i think really the viability
depends on the the
number of cells that are in there
because you have a high number of cells
they'll get big really fast and then
will show the necrosis faster than a
lesser dense
spheroid model
and we have a few more questions so um
how many of how many other tissue types
or
cancer types can you apply uh this
methodology to
yeah so what we um from
the webinar i think the methodology
talked about can be applied to
pretty much uh any of the different
cancers uh types that are available for
a cancer cell line and the uh you know
using the optimization that we
showed in this webinar with the caveat
that one method will not apply to all
lines
uh that's all lines that that are
available but
we should the the webinar that and the
tips that i provided should at least
give you some idea of
how to um uh to grow them for a bigger
length of time or to a particular size
so
you can use other canvas cell types
utilizing the tips that were
highlighted here
excellent next question
how do you determine what seating
density you need for the sphere or
generation
uh yeah um i guess with it again it
depends on the cell type that you're
using so
i i think if i you know you have to take
into account
how fast it takes a cell line to reach
that optimal
size of 300 to 500 micrometers and
um on certain cell types that we have
which we show
uh that we've optimized
internally uh we have uh some images
brightfield standing or our
live destiny show you the morphology as
well as the health of the cells based on
different seating densities and lengths
and culture so uh you know i definitely
would you know be sure you
you know read that if you're looking at
our protocols
and read the tips that are provided in
the protocol for alcohol growth uh for
example
for the t47d uh breast cancer line uh
it is recommended and i'm glad that our
research and rng team uh
uh found this out that growing them at
densities of higher than 8000 cells
or more will produce the narcotic
steroids
are rather uh rather fast so um
if you know you need them in culture
longer you know you'd want you probably
would not want to go to that
particular cell type uh so i mean it's i
think
you really have to factor in how long
you're going to have them in culture but
also
uh that's just to establish the line but
how long you're going to add the drug to
see the effect on it too so
that will play a role in terms of how
long it's going to be in culture
total but also how much you need to
start with and i would recommend going
smaller lower in the density to add the
development time but also
the drug testing time as well
great the next question have you worked
with mesenchymal cells
and have you seen extracellular matrix
on um
these i guess uh i
uh personally have not worked with the
mesenchymal cells in
a sphere setting based on the protocols
that
we've used uh that i've highlighted here
i've used them in combination
with the bio printer to develop a
different type of model
um
so i that for your question and i i
don't think i could i could um
recommend uh any recommendation on this
uh but i could reach out to you i'll
find a
to address any uh issue any questions
you have and possibly relay them
uh to our internal team uh to help you
with any questions you have with the
messenger cells
great thanks the next question
um when would i use a plate based
characterization assay versus an
image-based one
yeah so again the plate-based assays are
used for it's a relative quantitation
of a particular characterization
parameter you're looking at
uh the again depressive blue viability
assay again gives you
relative cell health data without giving
you a sense of
or an image of uh how much cell death is
present so
uh we would use this type of assay the
play base for
quick assessment of cell health for your
model but again for more detailed
information you know we
i recommend uh image-based assay such as
the live dead
assay or you can look at other
parameters such as uh hypoxia
uh or um or or oxidative stress
uh and with those types of image-based
acid you can visualize the amount of
depth but also quantitate uh
the loss of viability uh based on the on
an individual secured basis so
it depends on how much detail that you
want uh with that with your measurement
okay and i see one other question
um how do i image a spheroid
that's in suspension and floating in a
whale
yeah it's a definitely a common question
uh these are you know cells that are in
suspension
as opposed to adherent stuff so they're
not really fixed uh at the bottom
uh one thing especially if you utilize
our uh our
high content platforms we develop a
particular uh
program a program to assist with this
type of uh
uh functions the eureka scan finder
which allows for a seek and scan
functionality of
uh your spirit within a well so when you
apply this finder
uh the steroids or or the uh
in the will are identified during a
particular seek operation
at a low magnification so it actually
will in one shot with the low magnitude
will
find the spirit in the well and once
it's found it might
automatically have a second uh scan at a
higher magnification to give you the
high end resolution
so this utilizing this finder reduces
the imaging time
as well as your file size significantly
usually in a
normal scan of a well it does
individual like say 10x uh scans which
uh can take there's like probably like
25 of them in a particular well which
adds to a lot of your scan time you're
doing the the low mag then high mag
you're really just taking two uh two
quick shots again
reducing your uh your imaging time and
the actual number of files you're uh
that you're saving improving the
efficiency of how you analyze your model
okay the next question um
for drug testing do you recommend less
than a thousand
cells or just less than eight thousand
uh yeah i have again it is self uh
cell line dependent and will depend on
how long you're going to have them in
culture
uh i probably would not go with a
they sort of roll someone i probably
would not go with eight thousand because
i think
with most of the cell lines that'll uh
if you if you need to carry them out for
creating the model then adding a
particular uh drug it'll probably
uh the cells will i think will be
necrotic in the middle so
i would recommend on the lower side and
it may take a bit of optimizations
uh on on your end to see which works but
i would
um some cell lines that we have uh do
work
uh at less than a thousand cells if you
carry them out long enough
uh some you know will require a thousand
or two thousand so so
um i would go on the on this on the
lower end
for sure if you're if you're trying to
figure out how to uh time it for
growth and also testing
thank you i think that's the last of our
questions
um let me just see if there's any that
are coming in
if not um edwin thank you
um and do you have any final comments
for our audience
uh yeah um again uh with this
uh webinar but also on our our website i
mentioned that some of the uh
uh the resources that we have available
you know we support
really here at thermo fisher the entire
3d cell culture workflow
uh today we're talking about how to
create a model
keyword model but we can also support
you with the characterization
looking at cell health and functionality
but also how to image and
uh to image analyze so we can
what we provide in terms of support is
how
we can support you from all different
aspects of the 3d cell culture workflow
so
definitely have any questions regarding
any of that please feel free to contact
me or you know just pick on our website
we've got a lot of material
uh application notes uh brochures uh to
highlight a lot of the products so
[Music]
definitely you know we're here to help
you on your 3d journey
excellent thank you again edwin for your
time today
and for sharing your research um and
some of the ongoing initiatives
at therma fisher i would like to also
thank
um lab roots for hosting today's
educational webcast but before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for
their interesting questions and the
questions we didn't have time to get to
today
and those submitted during the on-demand
we will
be addressed those will be addressed by
edwin
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
so this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab groups will alert you via email
when it's available for replay so please
also share the email with your
colleagues who have
may have missed today's live event
until next time thank you and goodbye